ovni théâtral
r je n'ai su eyssautier pas le choix et
fair use vous présenter par ma bouche
hamamouche
par mes lèvres une mauvaise pièce de
théâtre maly fric et mal joué par des
brevets canadiens
merci ni sa peine ni mauvais en anglais
j'ai mes boss tu très mauvais je voulais
très belles présenté merci beaucoup
quels outils du passé comme ça va passer
des petits fous aux pâtissiers dame
selon moi même je vais les prendre un
petit plugin java me regagner
châssis sain me voici tout seul au coin
du feu
eh bien lisons mais quelle heure petit
bien-être au maire les reverrai relève
jamais ça leur taper dessus voilà on se
rend compte encore à ça qu'ils disent
déjà comme le temps passe vite et
estelle qui n'est pas encore rentré mais
j'entends la sonnette du vestibule
j'entends la soul est comestible qui
sommes frappés
tiens on frappe
entrer ses fins
ssl un seul bonjour blaise
ah c'est toi mon contrat
je t'ai l'iran à auxerre tenue tu vois
j'écrivais mes même score accroché
aujourd'hui j'aurai la bougera
mais on comme ça voilà blême
je suis madeleine glaise et pierre et
bien et bien si tu te voyais ces
principes est aussi précis que je règle
et gromit escaliers mais soyons vieux
conrad
nous habitons le rez de chaussée ciel je
me sens trahi je me ronge
jelasic mater dit non plus mais cela
n'est rien vieux conrad rend donc un
siège
j'ai pas de siège
ainsi nous voici la cie
ah oui je vais aller quérir une vieille
à bouteilles qui fais ce que tu veux
d'un derrière les fagots de la meilleure
marque bradley lui dirai chevaux lourds
secrets n'encourra reste coi droite
n'arrive qu'à leurs patients
alors voici entretien l'empathie à
tarbes a fait pas souvent
tiens tout moi son bon vieux porto
andré seulement avant tu n'es pas une
femme honnête tu as été commis ce cas
vous que toi aussi
c'est vrai dire seulement mais dans ce
sens n'a as et il amusant celui ci aussi
m'esclaffer
qu'est-ce qui joue bien ce type l'air
serge a fait tilt
oui direct à la taille
cette grille mais non mais non
a propos je vois ton costume que tu est
en deuil mais non je ne suis pas au
reste de condor changement
je suis pas en tête que conrad ou plutôt
si je suis un deuil moralement à
l'environnement mais mon dieu que je
reviens à ma violente demande mondiale
en miettes poignant faire estelle
comment vis-tu pauvre conrad tu t'es
trahir allons népalaise plus bête que tu
as l'air de nous deux il ya un bel un v6
les bières c'est surtout pas moins à
gène pas l'entendre dire qu'est ce
qu'ils jouent bien stipule nous méritons
qu'elle est dans ce court août secours
où se courront j'aime ces petites mains
ma femme est à concubine mac en civil
même qu'une cuisine combine oui conrad
ma femme tu la laisses
on sait pas mais la virgule
c'est parce que je joue trop vite des
temps mais je sais plus lentement mais
me voici au pied du mur est au pied du
mur
j'ai une forte envie
de te dire oui j'avoue jamais cette
liste ont existé
nous aimons estelle a ainsi donc j'en
perds en un seul jour ma femme et mon
meilleur ami un saint ni trop mais
quelle est cette douleur qui m'envahit
les gens y va du ciel je ne puis plus
bouger à le docteur me l'a fait bien dès
qu'une notion nouvelle m'intéresserait
ac je souffre battus si on s'ennuie pas
ou 3d puisque pour toi donne moi une
chaise parce qu'ils savent comment ces
deux prénoms mais c'est la mienne
ah je ne jamais sans son père au siège
que je sors
oh oh que je suis
mais pas vu un petit boulot
et bien voiture le voici dans mes
meubles rencontre albi 15 veuves à
boissy à 6 8 15 mais je rêve la tension
s'est bien cru la rejoindre rennes je
lui pardonne si des mois les heureux
tous les deux je l'appuie tête mais cela
n'est rien vieux courra dans ce monde ça
c'est pas faux pas de main morte ça la
verrière dieu george
je ne vous oublierai pas dans mon
testament destin un destin que tu vas
faire une vidange interdit ou non nous
nombreuses ici mais non mais non
religieuse imminent mais n'ont pas
réussi les sillons et noomi noirs ici
les il a aussi ajouté fatigue
le paratonnerre jane muia je pars
rassurer tous les garçons et maintenant
qu'il est parti nous et maintenant qu'il
est parti mais que des fonds importants
que jamais il faut qu'on en finisse une
fois on n'est pas content de l'heure
qu'il est mais moi faites quelque chose
en place à mayol
pouvait bouger je pourrais me noyer dans
la pièce non belle initiative
j'y cours il s'est pendu